سمعت الشهر الماضي أن منتدى أسبن الأمني
للرئيس الأوكراني يناقش
الوصول البطيء لأنظمة الأسلحة المتقدمة
من الغرب،
ما الذي تحتاجه أوكرانيا الآن، وما الذي
يمكن أن يحدث فرقًا ذا معنى،
بالتأكيد، الصواريخ الأطول مدى
مثل صواريخ أتاكوم،
نظام الصواريخ التكتيكية التابع للجيش والتي  ستكون
إضافة كبيرة جدًا للقدرات الأوكرانية
وأعتقد أنها ستمنحهم
مدى أطول وستسمح لهم بضرب
الأهداف الروسية بعيدًا قليلاً عن
الخطوط الأمامية وهم
قادرون حاليًا على القيام بذلك، والآن إذا  لقد خططنا
لهذا بشكل صحيح، وفي هذا الوقت تقريبًا
كان من الممكن أن يكون لدينا طائرات من طراز F-16 تحلق
مع طيارين أوكرانيين، وهذا بالطبع
شيء لا يحدث في
الوقت الحالي، وسيحدث في المستقبل، لكنه
لن يكون جاهزًا لهذا الأمر على وجه الخصوص.  "
مرحلة العمليات الهجومية التي
يقوم بها الأوكرانيون
الآن ولكن هذا هو نوع الشيء الذي
سيحتاجون إليه بالإضافة إلى الشيء الآخر الذي
أود أن أقوله يومًا ما هو أننا بحاجة إلى
المزيد من الأسلحة غير التقليدية
للأوكرانيين، وبعضهم منهم"  إنهم
ينتجون أنفسهم مثل
طائرات Seabourn بدون طيار التي تمكنوا من
تصنيعها واستخدامها بشكل كبير
في البحر الأسود ولكن كما تعلمون أيضًا
بعض الصواريخ والقذائف الأخرى التي
تمكنوا من تطويرها، لذا أه جزء
من ذلك هو  شيء
يمكن للأوكرانيين تطويره وأشياء أخرى
بالطبع هي من الغرب
وآخر شيء أود قوله هو أن
استمرار إمدادات الذخائر وخاصة
قذائف المدفعية من عيار 155 ملم
ستكون ذات
أهمية بالغة للأوكرانيين
ويجب عليهم ذلك  كن جزءًا من أي خطة لمساعدتهم
خلال هذه الفترة،
ونوع من الحديث عن الطائرات بدون طيار، حيث
ينقل الأوكرانيون الحرب إلى
عتبة روسيا بشكل أساسي باستخدام
الطائرات بدون طيار، وقد رأينا الأضرار التي لحقت
بالمباني في موسكو، والهجمات على
السفن الحربية الروسية والسفن الأخرى في
صنع  إلى الميناء الروسي ماذا يعني ذلك
بالنسبة لهذا الصراع ومن الناحية النفسية
ما هو التأثير الذي يمكن أن يحدثه على الروس
حسنًا، أعتقد أن الطائرة بدون طيار كانت نوعًا من
القوة المضاعفة غير المتماثلة لهذه
الحرب وعلى وجه الخصوص الاستخدام الأوكراني
لهذه الطائرات بدون طيار أه من
وجهة نظر عسكرية  لقد كانت الطائرات بدون طيار
مفيدة بشكل لا يصدق، فهي لن
تُخرج روسيا من الحرب، ولكن من
الناحية النفسية، كما تعلم، فإن لها
بالتأكيد تأثيرًا على
السكان المحليين وخاصة في موسكو
وغيرها من المناطق التي
رأوا فيها بالفعل  هذه الطائرات بدون طيار في العمليات، لذا
فإن لها تأثيرًا نفسيًا كبيرًا
على السكان المدنيين الروس
بالإضافة إلى أنها تظهر أيضًا أن
الأوكرانيين يمكنهم استخدام أسلحة غير تقليدية
مثل الطائرات بدون طيار من أجل
تحقيق بعض أهدافهم، لذا فإن
ما يمكنهم فعله في جوهره هو
إنهم يساعدون في خلق نوع
من الجمود بين
القوات الأوكرانية والروسية، لكن بالنسبة لأوكرانيا فإن
حقيقة وجودهم
تسمح للأوكرانيين بالحفاظ على
استقلالهم وتسمح لهم بذلك على
الأقل في الوقت الحالي.  استمر الوضع
لفترة أطول قليلا، وهذا
شيء لم أكن
أتوقعه من قبل الكثير من الناس في
بداية هذه الحرب